hello welcome to
another night of chess and psychology i
am dorsa darachani
and we are gonna have a lot of fun
so as usual we're gonna spend an hour an
hour
a little bit more than that probably on
youtube
and watching one of my favorite games
favorite tournaments i guess that kind
of should be everybody's
history's favorite tournaments should go
with that uh it's
one of the um it's one of the games in
the tournament that
magnus managed to break kasparov's
record so that's kind of a big deal
um in 2012 i was kind of just getting
into chess
how old was i was like 13 14 so
to me like i knew of these giant pliers
but i didn't really
know much about what was going on in the
chess world so looking back and just
comparing of like what was i doing in
those years it's kind of funny to me
um we're going to be looking at magnus
polgar game
as a woman i kind of wish pogba had you
know
not lost this game but hey you win some
you lose some
and this was in
the london tournament the london classic
in 2012 and this was the last
it wasn't the last game of the
tournament but it was the last
win of magnus in that tournament the
next two rounds he made draws
so um technically this kind of really
contributed to the rating difference so
i kind of
uh chose this one and yeah i really like
this game
um it has so much so much to offer
oh from belgium lovely yeah and uh
gia she's also with us i kind of came
home today
a little later than i usually would
because i
um i had a little too much tylenol
i got my second dose of vaccine today so
i'm tiny bit sore i don't have any
symptoms
tiny soreness which is expected when
needles goes inside of you
all right yeah so uh peachy is kind of
just
hovering over making sure mama is okay
all right uh if there are no questions
let's go ahead and get started
and um to finish up this game so we can
do the segment of switch to twitch and
um look at some of your personal games
by the way if some of you here
are like multitasking and doing some
games under and listening to my voice
from
like sidelines that's perfectly fine
just make sure the games that you play
you keep them
have the links ready for to send to me
when we switch to twitch in about an
hour
all right so let's go ahead and get
started
um there was a lot of other games that
magnus won before this
and i strongly recommend for you to
study that tournament it was such a
just like those those years of 2012 2013
was such a huge
uh historical years and chess just
because of how many
records magnus brought and then he
became the world champion 2013 so
you should definitely study those years
uh just
for even just the historical aspect of
it
and i feel like old person talking about
history
all right let's go ahead um so for this
game magnus chose to simply
start with the english defense
and then make a little transposition so
uh there is not much to talk about um
that deep in the opening but i kind of
want to get to um
get like a tiny um feeling of who here
plays
like this is there anybody who plays
this opening
i'm gonna probably wait about um 30 more
seconds and
get some inputs on this oh by the way
what do you guys any thoughts on
the upcoming match between carlson and
nepal
and i want to say like five months six
months
uh-oh she's having
i guess pcs
yeah technically this is not exactly my
choice either
i don't exactly play this as white or as
black
but eventually if there's going to be
some e4s which
flash news there was in this game it
kind of transposes into morocci and i do
play morocci so i like that
all right um let's keep that in mind and
just continue
all right so knight c3 normal normal
i kind of like this a3 it kind of
prevents this potential pin
um and it looks logical it doesn't
really need to be
too theoretical to um be able to
make sense of it yeah events i agree
i watched the interview that magnus did
too or i think it was also a tweet
following that uh i was so many news i'm
just
kind of mixing my sources but i do know
that magnus does consider him a worthy
opponent and he thinks it's going to be
a very interesting match so yeah
yeah i i like this idea with a3 and
um it's just like that's kind of like
the
the main reason i call this class chess
and psychology is not it's not because i
sit here and i teach you hypnotism
i wish i could uh but that's not the
reason the reason
is that um my
biggest chess philosophy is figure out
what your opponent wants to do and block
it
and that's some that's this a3 is
something like that
you figure out what your opponent wants
to do and if you block it you don't let
your opponent do what they usually like
to do and you do prophylactics you
do like blocking style
and yeah you don't make don't make life
easy
on your opponent so uh bishop bishop
gotta get out because he has still have
to castle knight b3 lovely
and finally this e4 now
uh what are your thoughts on this
position
to also to be fair i did like this idea
of bishop's e5 to kick the knight away
from center and then go back
as opposed to just bishop e7
but yeah so after e4 black still has to
get this bishop out and get this king
castle so let's start with the castling
because that's like
um the short way uh how it would turn
out
and as white we still have to figure out
what to do with the king
most likely it's going to be long short
castle long castle my pawn is on c4 it's
too weak
not worth it unless like super extreme
circumstances
yeah this is the this is the moroxy pawn
structure
um i'm more used to this pawn structure
with the g-spana g6 but
this is doable too yeah
um so after castle um
we still have to get this bishop out i
want to get few inputs on what you guys
think how do you think
we should get this bishop out should we
just cope with bishop simple bishop e2
should we try to push this pond what do
you think
any suggestions yeah i was thinking like
potentially i would like this bishop to
be more active in this diagonal too
because it's easy to assume that black
is going to
try to get this bishop from
the long diagonal as well but i don't
think that's
um that's very um doable because let's
say you play g3 right now
b6 you get your bishop out he gets his
bishop to a6
and this pawn is way too weak
under different circumstances if maybe i
was like a2
b3 potentially i could consider this
more seriously
but uh i can't really do this beyonce
idea because my c4 pawn would be a
weakness
yeah so let's just go ahead and play
normal let's get our bishops out
um polgar is also going to follow with
the plan to get her bishop out
all right now why to move
how else should we develop the next
logical piece to want to develop
is this bishop because at some point we
are going to want to do rook c1
that's just the normal flow of the game
i don't know if f3 is necessary i think
f3 is something that could come up in
the future
if needed but at the moment there are no
knight g4s
or nothing that serious attacking e4
so i feel like we can definitely keep f3
in the back of our mind but we don't
necessarily
need to um want to do it
so we've already cast though probably
let's get this bishop out where do you
think we should go
uh e3 i guess that's possible
but the problem my problem with bishop
on e3 is that it's not really attacking
anything
it's not really controlling any specific
squares
so
i don't really like that
any other potential suggestions for what
to do with this guy
what do you think fishy
he really wants to go outside and play
but it's kind of rainy here in santos
yeah bishop f4 bishop g5 again
similar issues my bishop is not really
doing anything and
also tactical
technical tactical problem mouse
that was not me and we can't really do
that because you did we
end up losing a pawn or more
so we have to be quite careful with how
we approach this we can't just
let our pieces fly around yep bishop f4
uh potential bishop d6 alert is
one thing to keep in mind for black and
let's see is there anything
else that i would want to
maybe in long term something with the
knights
but not at the moment i guess my cat
also has a lot of opinions to share
is she all right
um so bishop f4 obviously d6 should be
played
that's the most logical move now as for
white we mentioned
trying to get the rooks involved um one
thing we do know
is not necessarily sure if you want the
stroke to be on e1 or d1
but i do know that this stroke i wanted
to be on c1 so let's go ahead and do
that
also good support for potential c4 in
the future
rook c8 then once
now what should go on
maoski fish fish
he's really at the door just going at it
we're trying to open the door but he
can't because he's a tiny kitty
that's a sliding door
any suggestions oh thank you patrick any
suggestions with whitest
what to do
thank you brian yes basically
we have to make a decision on what to do
with this um
king and rook we're almost done with
making the
uh the
the transition from opening to middle
game i want to say that but that sounds
too cliche
uh knight b5 would be interesting if
there was no knight takes e4
see that's not gonna really hold
so that could give you the idea to just
simply play rookie one
i kind of like it's tricky one
anyone else
i'm not sure if that's a good sign or
not
oh
yeah um
yeah kind of the shift to middle game
but that sounds a little cheesy because
i feel like this is already middle game
just because the rooks aren't
technically
looking at each other directly doesn't
mean this is any less of a middle game
um
yeah so now what do we think about this
now
it's a direct attack against my pawn
and my pawn so
we kind of have limited options on how
to defend
boats uh exactly kind of yeah so
judith is kind of trying fighting for
peace activity over here
from um trying to attack and
get some of the center and of course
it's very important to
be able to do that because if you're not
activating your pieces then
what are you doing kind of um you know
makes you question
the chest style yeah so
everything is going great see kind of
that's the problem
um queen d4 well now
again bishop a6 can bring even more
to this c4 pawn
and i'm not the biggest fan of that
honestly i don't really want to have
this
c4 pawn hanging over my head
yeah knight d2 uh taking the knight
is possible but now your bishop is kind
of
naturally ideal and you are
dealing with the threat of exchanging
queens your opponent has the two bishop
i understand that the pawn structure
looks a little weird but
the e4 pawn is weak the c4 pawn is weak
there's a lot of weaknesses in the
position this is not an ideal this is
not an ideal thing like even if you try
to
like close it up again queen c7 uh peace
activity is much better your bishop is
kind of
weird now we shouldn't take that knight
but i do like knight d2
the knight is kind of getting a little
defensive but
now we can start the idea of pawn
expansion and the queen can't come to
the other side there's a lot of great
ideas yeah
knight d2 is the best one now
after knight d2
what do you think black is going to do
now
black can't really do the idea of pawn
expansion but white does want to
to do this pawn expansion what about
squares are there any cool squares that
black could want to jump into
isn't this night overloaded
a little bit but the black can't really
use that
a5 interesting but the problem with a5
is
that eventually i could try to start
kicking this knight away and if this
knife is kicked away this is a very weak
pawn
and then i can start to bring forces to
attack this guy
so i mean possible it's not the end of
the world to play a5
but um not it doesn't exactly go with
the
flow of black's position
okay i'm getting suggestions of trying
to maybe do bishop basics potentially
but
maybe let's look at which piece of black
is not working
this knight is working this bishop is
kind of working
this rook is in a good place the queen
could definitely be improved this true
could definitely
be improved but most of all um
what about this knight could this knight
potentially be improved
because if i managed to move this knight
then i could get my bishop to come over
here and my bishop would definitely be
improved
and we can also consider that this
knight this is not a permanent position
right because eventually white's gonna
move this bishop somewhere
and get this f4 yeah i like knight d7
i'm opening up this knight c5 idea
potentially going after
d3 square bringing more over here
opening some bishop of six ideas i like
this
so we know black wants to play knight c5
what do you think
white's gonna try and do
can we stop that somehow
i do think b4 is worth considering
but the problem with b4 is
that um
what if just asics
i do think b4 is worth considering
definitely
f5s do not really work at the moment
because
if you take with that then this is just
a bunch of weakness over here that's not
going to be a good choice for black
if you take with the rook i can just
move my bishop away and
again this is not a really optimal
position well actually i kind of like
bishop e3
i think b4 is doable yeah um however
remember one of the biggest things that
we want to do
is this f4 to kick this light away so
how about just bishop e3
if you were to play knight c5
now i could now this knight is also
going to be
under fire for this pawn that lands on
the back for that pawn
i can simply do a queen c2 to stop d3
stuff
and next move i'm going to kick your
knights one way or another
so i kind of like this one b4 is again
uh to respond to b4 definitely possible
um it was a game that
happened um between vanveli and goshimov
and
vacancy 2012 so same year just i guess
um
a few months before
and that's getting anything to draw and
that's it's it has a lot of potential
and
um that's that's doable again before
doable
but i guess magnus just kind of wanted
to splice it up and play something
differently so he went for bishop e3
nothing wrong with that either now queen
c7
now what should we do is it time to push
this one is the time to push the other
one
what shall we push
memo he she is sharing his thoughts with
us too
i like f4 i like b4 too
which one do you think is sneakier
so this is kind of a funny situation
because
i'll i'll give you a little um future
insight
in this game uh judith played this idea
and got the queen to a8
to push for on e4 and to have the queen
on the queen side
this is not a bad idea uh it just means
that
you have to be more cautious with your
with pushing your
pawns because it then like
the queen is somehow in the attack but
it's not exactly directly
you know attacking it it's kind of like
behind the forces waiting
so you just have to be careful of that
idea
uh there's a question of is my b5 free
tempo now
so technically i guess so but the queen
wants to go to a8
anyways so that doesn't really help us
again it's not that clear to me why the
queen would be better on
a8 on rather than d8 but
the queen on a8 kind of you know gives
like a tiny bit of harmony
so
yeah um so i'm not i don't think we're
going to
need f3 soon but it's good to just
keep the option open so like
the game white's game is in both king
side queen side and in the center
so it's good to be able to expand in all
sides
so let's start with b4 we said
we like we know what black wants to do
black wants to get this queen to a8
again it's not as clear as
why the queen on a8 is powerful
or even if um why polgar thought about
it
i can't speak of that but i do know that
the queen on 8 kind of feels a little
more involved in the game rather than
the queen on d8 because the queen on d8
was never really gonna be able to get
into the king side action
so potentially queen on a8 might be able
to keep an eye on the king's side and
the queen side so i think that's why
queen on a8 is being um
i guess recommended yeah i think that's
the right word to recommend it
not exactly queen on a8 has keeps some
potential for pawn marches
expanding keeps a little uh pressure on
the king side
might want to expand with f5 again big
might but still
so now my question to you should we play
f4
yeah exactly patrick this queen i hate
idea is present in bunch of other lines
as well
so what's the verdict should do we want
this f4
or not
oh okay so it's two it's
still kind of split
oh oh what do you think
alright so this is very very fun
this is so split all right
actually f4 was played and it is a great
move
it's like you're grabbing space on both
sides and
you are also denying this uh you're kind
of kicking this
central night away so
knight's got a move and it's kind of
funny because now all
of judith's pieces are in the this third
in this
three ranks why is error is public
it's not even a good move these three
are the only error uh
line files wait no lines that's judith
can have her pieces
which is kind of fun right it's kind of
funny when you think about it
question on f3 um
f3 put completely doable
but we don't need it
f3 is kind of against that
um that spirit of getting that much
space
so uh from what i understand magnus
really
really
really really loves to just get his
space start his dominance in this game
and just
show that i can have it all i can't have
the king side i can't have the queen
side i can have my pawns running i can
have my pieces flying
so that's kind of a psychological way of
thinking about it too
and f3 doesn't really go with that so
after
knight g6 what do you think white should
do
this move um was kind of weird to me
so i'm gonna wait for you guys to
mention a little bit of it exactly what
does have to be careful i agree
fish fish i'm not sure if you guys hear
how um vocal of my cat is being
f5 is too early no we will give back the
e5 square we don't want to do that
also keep in mind this bishop might
eventually come to f6
looks good on f6
queen b3 um doable
normal move
f5 or g4 or moves like that is not the
way to go
y's position is not ready the problem
the thing with queen b3 is that this d5
could be concerning
because of this knight takes f4 now that
we've talked about d5 d5 is another idea
that black is kind of cooking up
because of d5 now i'm going to be
attacking your f4 pawn
so we should potentially start
considering f4
as something to look after so what how
can we
um think about protecting my f4
pawn
knight b3 knight f3 i think that's like
on the to-do list we're eventually going
to move this knight
but yeah i see you guys are kind of
mentioning the g3 idea and i think g3 is
just
kind of feels like whoa this bishop here
is just
just well why why would i do this
it looks a little crazy i agree with
that statement
but it's not bad because you are
going to play this bishop f3 very soon
within the next
move or two and um so it's not
it's little weakening but it's not that
dangerous
so
what do we think
to be honest i don't know if i would
play g3 in my own game
yeah i don't think i would play g3 in my
own game
what would i do um
i don't know i don't like the idea of
rook f1
it's not bad but what would you do after
queen a8
eventually you're gonna want to play
this bishop f3
and then there's gonna be knight h4 as
well so it's a lot of it's a lot of
hassle
let's say if i had seen this game i
would consider g3 more seriously
but if i've never saw this game i don't
think i would even think about g3
yeah g3 it's a little dirty
rookie 8 bishop f3 see we talked about
how this bishop
wants to come to f3 i mean when you
think about it more logically you do
want bishop on f3
g3 protects both of these uh weaknesses
so
makes sense i guess but
i i can understand why it wouldn't be
anyone's first choice
anyone but magnus's first choice yeah
so let's get bishop f3 and here uh
judith played queen i8 queen i8 doesn't
feel um that
that's in sync with the written
um oh we got the cat on the table
hi crispy you missed attention
so why do you guys think what should
whites do while i try to see what the
cat wants
hello sir what do you want good sir
do i just find your head against my head
just want to show off your gorgeous face
and your
chunky neck to the audience
all right katie want to go on your tree
and let me teach oh
he's sitting at the microphone
i agree white should listen to the cat
the cat knows best
well i guess this is your new instructor
i'm just going to do a voiceover of his
majesty
the kitty yeah um
let's see what do we want here
point a four
we can also consider what do you think
would be best move for black here
so clint what point in the game but
um funny enough
something like asics was the best move
yeah
trying to have some control on the queen
side
and like if you try to put your bishop
in a better space and then
queen come come back um
yeah it's uh it's still a lot of things
going on
now he's sleeping on this
hi baby boy i want to go on your
tree
i feel like daenerys targaryen instead
of a dragon on my shoulder i have a
kitty on my shoulder
who can breed me out that wasn't as
funny as i thought it would be
alright
so um in this
position hello kitty kitty
um i agree asics would be
potentially more uh promising for black
but she decided to
go for queen a8 see that's another
aspect of psychology
when it's uh and chess when it comes
down to it
you want to be able to um
follow the plan but like even if the
plan was wrong
sometimes you're too committed to it now
this feels like
like one of those weird relationships
which we've all had
you know this person is wrong for you
they're like so many red flags but you
still do it
and then five months later you're
sitting here and being like hmm
what was wrong with me five months ago i
feel like that's
this is something that we do entrust to
i've
found so much parallel between just like
chess and real life
especially when i'm trying to think more
critically in my
life decisions especially because i'm
doing a lot of applications and personal
statements for medical schools and i
have to be able to
relate chess to daily life it's kind of
funny i keep coming up with fun
analogies
i was trying to teach one of my
seven-year-old students
why should she know end games and i was
telling her so end game is like dessert
do you like dessert and she was like
no then i was very um
it was very hard to for me to explain
why
she needs to know end game
yeah we landed on ice cream she said she
likes ice cream
so i we landed on that anyways
um so queen eight is like that it's like
bad decision that you
made already and you kind of already
committed to it and you're like hmm
should i do it and funny enough um
judith decided to to realize that this
was a bad decision
and she was like all right i guess i
wasted few
some moves and some energy and i gotta
come back
and that was that's such a huge thing to
understand and that's why
she is the best chess player the best
female chess player and
one of the best 10p 10 test players in
the world and like all the other things
that i can't even list off
because i we won't have enough times and
i don't
exactly remember from where to start
but that's the thing like she like
understanding your mistake admitting to
it and
making like after two moves remember
here she just played queen a8
and then she makes another move and then
she's like okay i understand my mistake
i'm coming back
it's such a huge thing and that's why i
think psychology is so important and
just
also in life but i can't exactly teach
you
life without chess
i think for that i would need to be a
licensed therapist i'm not sure if i
could do online group therapy
anyways yeah
uh i think um this idea with queen a4
was a possibility but my queen on a4 is
not exactly doing anything
the queen on e2 is protecting these
bishops is keeping everything tidy up
and it's kind of giving my nice
potential freedom to start
um i guess horsing around roaming around
yeah
yeah it was very fun that my
seven-year-old student
was like nah i don't really like dessert
and i was sitting there
and i was like man this is this kid's
going places
well currently fun is but i think she's
also taking a break from professional
chess so
honestly pandemic everybody is kind of
taking a break here and there
i heard one uh i read one how i was also
going to
retire from professional chess i think
at some point
everybody will come back to chess people
who retire
who retire very young but
anyways um so after queen b8
which piece of in our position could be
improved
i'm assuming the stroke because this
truck is just like protecting a pawn
that's already protected by
three other pieces four four other
pieces
so it makes no sense for this truck to
be here let's do this d1
have some new aspect for it
and here unfortunately polgar made
a serious mistake she played g6 g6 does
give
white advantage it kind of weakens the
dark squares
and if she kind of wanted to move a pawn
in front of the king to open some
breathing room h6 was the way to go
g6 is not the move g6 is not good at all
after g6 now we get simply e5 my queen
is in the optimal
position my rook is in there too my
pawns are all defended
my bishop is egg everything everything
is very well synced together
exactly black also has no space she
probably wanted to create some from g7
anywho this after this e5 that doesn't
really help black's
space problem so e5
and black continued and she played
bishop c6 i'm assuming that this
idea was to be able to continue it
with um trying to get more activation
at some point because you're not gonna
wanna take this just
yet i can simply take it with the knight
my rock becomes
more open it's not it's not ideal at all
so also keep in mind taking is not
ideal because simply take if you decide
to take this with the knight
then i can simply take that guy and your
piece hangs
uh if you decide to take over here
after i take back well that's perfectly
fine for me too
that i'm simply defending it no biggie
so in the game uh you did just went for
bishop c6 yeah now what do you think we
should do is whites we still gotta
get our pieces involved try to identify
the one piece that could be better
and make it better
what do you think
getting knight to e4 maybe
but remember bishop c6 also frees up
this idea to take
yeah you have to be quite careful with
that one
and gmp she's having a snack
uh yeah we have to be careful uh it's
not the right time to want to move these
nights
i don't wanna i don't wanna lose my
central pawn so let's come defend that
pawn
this this game is one of my favorite
because it's just so
logical you're not going crazy and
sacrificing here and there and like
doing crazy calculations
you're simply playing normal moves
you're figuring out what opponent wants
i'm just blocking it
so bishop d4 uh you'd have played rook
d8
logic but king is kind of weak so i have
to be careful with that
now i can just take that take and then
knight f3
my knight is joining to fight
taking over squares opening up my rook
so many different things in the game you
do
took and now she played dirk c8 now what
do you think we should do here
as white
oh magnus flaming dismissal i didn't
think about that
i can see that though yeah
knight e4 i love it good one yeah
i see more and more of the viewers are
agreeing with this knight e4
and i am all for it yep knight e4
that is a good choice uh i like this
idea with knight e4
especially uh because when we do this
knight e4
it's not that we're just attacking
squares we're putting pressure and
that's what's
more important with nice e4 you're
taking away squares you're putting the
pressures you're doing
all these and you also have the threads
but you see you don't really have you're
not
really worried about anything in your
queen side that's the beauty of it
exactly those moves such as g3 or bishop
d4 look kind of weird
but they're very logical yep
so uh this pawn is a little weak so
you're just trying to use it
now this was so funny for me
how do you think white is going to
defend that pun
yeah guys blunder is not a sacrifice
that's uh
nope uh-uh that's a big no no no no
blundering not a sacrifice
you can't just call the sacrifice
because you want to
blundering is blundering and there is no
covering it up
sorry
no careful you don't want to lose your
pawn
how do we defend this poor guy
okay okay ic92 is becoming more
promising in the chat
yes but be careful we just played this
one to e4 we don't want to bring that
one back
let's do the the other one the knight on
e4 is much more powerful than knight on
f3
now we're not really worried about this
take because we simply have b5 and the
stroke becomes in a
pickle jar goes in a pickle jar so
uh you just made another mistake here
and she sorry
you didn't make a mistake right now she
played a6 because we were doing b5
she protected the rook and uh
now um magnus played a very cute move of
knight f2
i'm assuming he's simply trying to you
know move it around
dance with the knight there's so many
cool ideas
and here judy made a mistake she played
bishop g5 what do you think we should do
here
as what
what to do and why is this such a bad
move
chess is hard i agree with that no
not queen g4 nope not those moves
funny enough rook f1 is the best one
your roof's job here
is kind of over rook f1
it's time to bring the rook to go attack
bigger fish
yeah we're not really worried about the
c4 pawn take
take and if you take on e5 all right
perfect
i'll just take that back and knight g4
my knight is much more active
than it i could ever actually dream of
and i'm also using my rook's activity
to support that as well yeah this is the
best way to go for it
so judith is trying to form a counter
play with rook d6
but we're not going to exchange the
queen so you're simply going to give
this check
and followed by another check careful uh
king eschato is not
going to work because we're simply going
to take over there
and then take the rook so king g7 was
forced to tank
and now we're simply going to move this
queen
we don't want to exchange queens so we
let's keep the queen somewhere
uh cool queen f2 is possible yeah
um queen d4 just have to kind of be
cautious of that
now what do you think
now we we're not exactly going to jump
at the opportunity to take this queen
because then the drug takes and then the
rook gets activated so
how can we keep our peace activity and
uh kind of wait for opponents to
exchange the queen
magnus is like smithslave on steroids i
never thought that would come to my mind
but hey
you do what you gotta do
rook f1 careful with your c4 palm but
we're not ready to give that up
c4 pawn is a weakness in the game magnus
played
c5 how do you feel about that
i think c5 is pretty decent um you're
trying to
it's just very difficult with this but
that's not that's not the point the
point is that
uh if you decide to take it that's good
if you decide to take over here even
better i'll take that back
and then i can um
just hold on sorry
lipstick i could simply take that back
with the rook
now if i want to give you a check over
here if you decide to
bring the king up now i can do little
fun stuff
i think this would be the little more um
exciting way to play this game yeah
um again trying to play
taking with the king your pieces are
still active enough that you would
enjoy this game uh you can go for like
924 you can jump over here
jump over there it's perfectly doable
but you don't necessarily have to
um you don't have to do
that you don't only have one option yeah
so in the game judy just took over here
take
you have to take take take don't take
because that will be
fun now this guy is also in the pickle
um that would be kind of a fun part to
play and okay so
rook d8 now what do we do this game is
almost over we got about 10 more moves
how do you plan to continue so another
another part to um
think about it is that your
um you did like it
you converted your advantage
um you had this cool advantage in the
spatial wise and then you um gave up a
pawn
and then you converted that advantage
into this endgame
which you still have lots of advantage
especially
due to peace activity so now the
question is how do you plan to use it
oh the cat me out because he knows
so i kind of like the idea of doubling
my rooks up any objections
whoops yeah we should double these rigs
up
oh pc i doubled my rooks up
yeah we double these rooks up uh i guess
double them up double them on the
seventh rank
yeah and um check
up check up and you're out of checks
so he tries to go uh she sorry she tries
to go for
different type of check and what do we
do now
this knight's all job is also kind of
done here it would be much more powerful
if it was on f6
right
what do you think peach bush any more
suggestions from gmp
she i guess meowing peachy
what i called you by your full name
yeah let's go for knight g4 thank you
apple juice
yeah knight g4 we want to go for an eye
type six
we don't want to do this rook c5b we
like these rooks
being on focus on h7
yeah we're getting ready to do this
wreckage saturn idea yep
check all right the only move to do
check
all right i'm gonna move it and here
polgar was like okay well this knight f6
is very scary so i'm going to go for
rook f5
careful we don't want to take this we
don't want to rush into it just go for
king e3
and now kind of have to take because if
not this is falling and also knight f6
is coming
up so taking is forced
basically we take back attacking this
guy and this guy
rook d8 is again forced knight f6
this king very very stuck can't go
anywhere
this knight has to stay here to defend
this district has to stay in this
uh rank to defend this so black is just
kind of uh what do you say sitting duck
yeah i believe that's expression sitting
duck
right fish and sooner or later
this king is just gonna slowly slowly
come up and win
so uh in the game judith played rp8
trying to still put up a fight king up
uh ideally we could also just go over
here
because i would then want to give you
checkmates with taking over here
and well i guess not checkmate but if my
king is here i could do this rook g7
rook g8 so that looks pretty cool too
so judit was like okay i don't want to
get checkmated
now king e5 yeah just kind of chilling
eventually you're gonna run out of moves
uh
she played a5 and yep
easy peasy take okay ain't a6 it's not
like you're gonna take this because i'll
take your knight
and you can't really do anything with
your knight you can't move this night
because checkmates or i'll eat your
night
either one should be good for me so yeah
black is in a
beginning to you know go in a very sad
swan
and this is just lost unfortunately
yeah even if you take this there's no
um points in it's just
i can just do d8 honestly
and then this checks also coming up yeah
um
here she resigned and that is one
of the games that contributed to the
overall
tournament of london classic 2012
in which magnus broke kasparov's
rating record and became
the highest rated chess player in the
world
in the history of chess he has also
broken bunch of other records and his
personal records and everything since
then we're not gonna get into that
but this was one of the beautiful games
and i kind of wanted to show one of his
games
in um today because
the candidates ended very recently
we didn't matter if i want to say hours
and so
we know that nepomnechi is going to be
challenging magnus
in november slash december of this year
so technically by the end of the year we
should
know if we're going to stay with the
same world champion or if you get a new
one
either way i really wanted to kind of
dive into one of his games
initially i wanted to maybe show some of
the history of nepal vs magnus
but i thought this was a bigger moment
we can always do that next week too
we have months to talk about nepo
versus magnus so with that in mind
i am going to say bye to you probably
for about seven to ten minutes until i
switch the whole thing and go to twitch
our favorite segment of switch to twitch
and probably grab tea and eat something
sweet
definitely water maybe calm the cat down
because he's meowy
very meowy yeah so i'll see you in about
seven to ten minutes on twitch be sure
to show up follow subscribe you know the
drill
and have your games ready to send to me
from leeches
um as a link on the chat so i'll see you
in about five
seven to ten minutes and for those of
you who can't join us
well we do this every week so have a
game or two ready and join us next week
all right